Are they God or are they gods? No. One
in purpose because Jesus said the father
is greater than I.
>> Are they are they are they one or the
father is greater?
>> So to harmonize between two statements
he is talking about the purpose
>> they have the same purpose. Okay.
>> So also does God have a god? change your
>> so if Jesus God should have no God but
in the Bible Jesus said I'm going to my
God and your God to my father and your
father and you just told me God doesn't
have no God so therefore Jesus cannot be
God because they have a god
you know in the Quran Allah said yeah
about Jesus and his mother
both of them used to eat food Why Allah
mentioned that is not the nature of the
most high. Cuz if you are in need of
food, you cannot be the same God who is
self-sufficient, who was not in need of
anything.
Look at this one verse which is a
rational, logical, tangible argument to
destroy the trinity to show you to
debunk trinity. Can you give me the
>> the verse?
>> Is it in the Quran?
>> Is in the Quran? Yeah.
You only have English
good points. You bring good points.
Look what Allah said. Yeah. Allah said
I don't have it. No, I don't.
>> So, go. If you go to the translation
>> uh verse, okay, verse 75
verse
here.
Oh, it's English. It's Arabic. It's not
English.
>> Oh, I see.
>> It's here. It's here.
>> Don't know why they
>> verse 75.
>> Um, are these also like um teachings?
You know how like man,
>> you know what I'm saying? how there's in
the New Testament.
>> I don't know how the Quran works. And
he's also like teachers.
>> What's that?
>> Ah, he's asking like is the Quran like
New Testament, Old Testament? How is the
sequence of the Quran? He's asking
>> Allah said the Messiah, son of Mary who
was not but a messenger. Other
messengers have passed on before him and
his mother was a supporter of truth.
They both used to eat food. Look how we
make clear to them the signs. They look
how they are deluded.
>> How can you believe God that Jesus was
God but he was in need of breast milk.
>> You understand? Because the default
nature of you and I as humans is that we
need nutrition. Some people took Mary as
a god. And Allah mentioned in the Quran
>> they would eat food. Why? Because
>> gods are not in need of food only
humans.
>> So it shows weakness and the attributes
of God first and foremost be powerful.
>> No fatigue can come over God. God cannot
be overcome by fatigue. He's not in need
of nutrition, apples and fruits and
pears. So this is the reason why he
mentioned that verse. So
>> and also if you eat food you have to
respond to nature to the nature of
nature.
>> The core of nature the call of nature.
All of that is human nature. It's not
God's nature.
You know, that's why look, we believe if
you want to really believe in Jesus,
then the Quran says you what what Jesus
really preached.
Okay? Also in the Quran, Prophet
Muhammad, if he was a false prophet,
how come in the Quran there's no chapter
has been named after his own mother? But
there is a chapter in the Quran has been
named after the mother of Jesus called
the chapter of Mary.
Are you aware of that?
>> It's a long chapter. It's a long
chapter.
>> Chapter and he mentioned the story of
Mary, how she got pregnant and how Allah
protected her owner cuz you know the
story of the Quran about Mary when she
got pregnant is more logical rational
than the story of uh the Bible. So do
you believe in the verse? Yes, I believe
Allah
created Jesus through Mary like he
created Adam without a father and a
mother like he created Adam. He created
Eve without a woman but from a man.
Allah wants to show us and manifest his
power his power that he's able to create
a man without a man and a woman. And
he's able to create a woman from a man
not a woman. And is able to create a man
from a woman not a man
is able to do all things.
You know so the story of the Quran
remember the Israelites they used to
stunt the adulterer.
>> Imagine a woman coming to them claiming
she got pregnant and no one touched her
and God gave her a child.
the story of the Bible that Andrew
Gabriel or the Holy Spirit came to
Joseph the carpenter
to cover her up but the Quranic story
that Allahh made a child Jesus when he
was in the cradle to speak and defend
the honor of his mother that's why they
couldn't because imagine you have a
daughter and she comes to you and she
said I have a child I'm pregnant I have
a child and you ask her how
this
They have a child and ask her how she
would say uh what do they call it? Uh
God gave it to me. I'm not married. I
had no sex. Nothing. You're not going to
believe her. Say you feel I'm stupid.
But if she says to you, I'm going to
show to you this child is from God. The
child will start speaking to you in the
cradle.
The child has to be
one second. Yes.
Okay.
>> Yeah. So, the Quranic story is more
logical rational.
>> What do you think said so far? So far, I
know you're very well read on this. I
don't know if you are a teacher. You
seem like a teacher so far. That's what
I've understood. Um, you bring good
points. Obviously, some of these things
I cannot fully understand because I've
not read and
they dispute my beliefs.
>> But you know what, Paul? You know what
I'm speaking about? I'm not I'm not
really speaking about some deep detailed
issues
or matters. I'm speaking about sav
foundation. Every human being with a
sound intellect will understand it. If
someone comes to me said you claim that
Allah is the god of everything but Allah
doesn't know someone's name that is
submission to start saying you know what
it cannot be called anymore because
Allah knows everything.
You understand? So that's why I'm
speaking about speaking about something
which one of one of the miracle of Islam
he goes in line with the sound intellect
and the natural effluation
Islam there's only one God the creator
of everything the greatest based upon
his wisdom and his justice he chose
people amongst us from our kind like
Jesus Moses Abraham Noah Jacob Isaac the
last prophet Muhammad wasallam to teach
us how to worship God and how to follow
God's teaching
But none of these prophets were God or
they should be worshiped beside God. And
we believe all the prophets and
messengers. We believe in Moses,
Abraham, Jesus, all of them. But we
don't we don't worship Allah. We don't
raise the level of Allah.
>> You understand? Likewise, we believe in
the books that God gave the messengers
in order to guide mankind with it. You
understand?
>> You spoke of foundation.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Before we started this
conversation, as we started, one of the
things I asked was
>> whether you believe resurrected and came
back from the dead and you said no
>> because you cannot prove it in the Quran
tell us
>> of of course so the Quran tells you but
then the Bible tells us that this did
happen and there is witness there are
witnesses in [music] the Bible
>> there are there not none none none of
the people
>> again sorry have you read Hebrew 5:7
>> I've read Hebrew but I cannot completely
>> Hebrew 5:7 clearly shows us that Jesus
was not crucified. He was saved.
>> You can get Hebrew 5:7.
>> Let me get Hebrew 5:7.
>> All right. Do
>> you have Muhammad Suden's number
>> somewhere?
So, should I read it?
>> Yeah, read it. Oh, go ahead.
>> I got it. In the New International
Version.
>> Yeah.
>> During the days of Jesus's life on
earth, he offered up prayers and
petitions with fervent cries and tears
to the one who could save him from
death.
>> And he was heard because of his reverent
submission.
>> And Jesus said, "Whatever I ask God, he
will do it for me." So here Jesus was
asking God to save him and he said he
was heard. God doesn't have to you don't
have to be a good man for God to heal
you.
>> Meaning his prayer his supplication was
heard.
>> He was accepted that God save you from
the death.
>> And I'm not saying there's other
passages says Jesus was crucified but
shows you there's discrepancies in the
Bible.
>> Let's read that again. Wow.
Sorry. Are you aware there's other
gospels which were not included in the
cannon of the New Testament? It says
that Jesus was saved and he was not
crucified. But the Christians don't
accept it. There was many gospels
secreting around at the time of Luke,
the time of Paul, the time. But the
Christians don't accept it anymore. Why?
What is the criteria that Christian
utilize to accept some gospels and to
reject others?
>> What is the criteria? You know,
>> I will not speak from ignorance because
I
>> you know what the first Christian I
heard say that in a long
>> Yeah. You're a very humble person.
>> Yeah. It's good to study and read.
There's no criteria, brother. What they
did is you can see what they start
accepting the gospels that goes in line
with the agenda.
because they cannot tell you with an
objective criteria why this gospel would
even now Catholic they have more books
in their Bible than the Protestants
likewise the the the Christian uh
Ethiopian Christians they have more
books
so what is the criteria
>> is the issue
honestly
>> that's what we do as a Muslim is
consistent
has never been changed Never any writer,
any never doctrine, any
>> never and you cannot. You know why? I
give you a living example to show you
the Quran will never be corrupted. Not
to the Jewish people and the Christians
and the Muslims, all of us will decide
to burn our scriptures. Say, you know
what? Let's get rid of our scriptures.
We should have nothing in the written
form. The only scripture will remain
with us is the Quran because it has been
memorized by 100 million of Muslims and
we can bring it back into into written
form. You know who can do that? Our
scholars our scholars are able to do
that. Even the Muslim children at the
age of 10 11 who are millions of of them
memorize the Quran word for word. So,
and this is the case in the Muhammad has
been memorized you know like you know
the alphabet A B CDE E I can I can say I
can write A O U but everyone will say no
you're making mistakes it's A B C D
>> thank you very much sir
>> you're welcome let me give you something
>> thank you for your time thank you for
your time have a good one yeah
>> yeah guide you man
>> for that one
to conclude we asked her to guide him he
was listening And he was being humble
but you can see the truth was very heavy
on him. So we ask Allah to guide him to
the truth.
>> Alhamdulillah you can see even himself
said he said he struggles with his own
belief.
>> It doesn't make any sense. The greatest
the creator of everything became a baby
and he's the same one who is perfect all
the time but he became imperfect and
he's self-sufficient but he was in need
of his mother to breastfeed him.
Alhamdulillah. May Allah guide you to
prom.